and i made
i made like around 15 000 for my first
short
everyone always says learn the business
side of the film industry
what does that really mean and how do
you learn it
well we need business with any industry
you're in
um
you have to understand that after you
make this beautiful picture beautiful
project
now it's the marketing side
it's getting it distributed who's going
to pay for it that's the business out of
it a lot of times we make this beautiful
project
and they was like okay it's beautiful
who's gonna pick it up
you gotta promote yourself you almost
gotta be a mayor because he hasn't shake
babies and that's the business out of it
because once you do a project it need to
be out there and then get out there so
the business side is
i'm done with this baby now time to fix
it up
and put out in the world and that's what
you got to do and if you don't have the
business side
get someone that have your best interest
to help you with it because a lot a lot
you know it's all about delegation like
in my team i know i'm the quarterback
i'm gonna if you want a super bowl
you're gonna come over here but i do
need defensive line i mean a wide
receiver it's a team effort um the film
industry is a team effort so you want to
get people in your best position that
can help you but the business side is
learning the business
of whatever you're doing
if you're a singer if you're an artist
if you're a barber of your hairstyle you
got to know the business but if not
you will be taken advantage of
so speaking of being taken advantage of
we know that you know film industry
attracts
all kinds and people with all different
intentions
and
you said something about if if you don't
know the business side then get someone
how do we know who to trust especially
in the beginning especially when people
know someone's new at something
maybe in the film industry there tends
to attract some
some flies
how do we know
is it really time for us to trust
someone you research first
so i mean when i first started i needed
a lawyer to do a contract for me
but sent told me he was shady i just you
like the signs are there so i just
researched the contract this contract he
gave me he tried to do a contract with
me i didn't like it but i researched it
went online if i don't understand this
word let me google the word a lot of
times
we get taken advantage of
we don't take the extra protection step
so if you have a nice house
take that extra step to get security
cameras
a lot of times we just got to do that
because at the end of the day
you might get taken advantage of it
depends how bad you can take advantage
of that's the engine like just life
ain't fair i got taken advantage of
before but it's all about how how bad is
the damage it's like prevention if you
have a security camera and someone's
trying to break in your house your dog
might just save they might break in one
entry but that dog might just save it
could be really bad
so it's all about
doing the research um whoever you get
just try to do the research and then a
lot of times the signs are there you
just gotta listen a lot of times you
wanna see the good in people could be so
hungry and ages but the signs are they
just gotta pay attention but do the
research so if you hire in a producer
and they say hey mad fat i give you a
great example i don't remember the guy
name but right now in la this guy just
sang
tons of people i'm sending you a guy's
article but tons of people at a million
dollars
no one did a research
in 2021
he did a almost half a billion dollars
sam
you tell me no one did no research
nobody
so
after a while you just gotta do the
research and know who you're dealing
with you know we you could google
somebody could do background checks do
do that extra security because if not if
you take advantage of first time i
didn't know second time
third time then you just you got to do
your you got to do delicious yes
okay so if someone doesn't have money
though to pay for a pi firm
or
sometimes there's not a lot of stuff on
someone online
you said you gotta sense those because
sometimes someone's intuition will tell
you more than whether they look good on
paper or not
and so what was that intuition that you
got
about this person in the beginning
sometimes that intuition you can't
explain it you just know it
um you can't even describe it it just
because everybody different it could be
someone that's really really nice and
still take advantage of you so something
you got to trust your gut and the signs
are there so it's hard to explain it but
in my case um
the lawyer
was name-dropping too much
to me there's always a red flag and
we're having a conversation they keep
name-dropping and name-dropping and
name-dropping it becomes a red flag
especially
when i ask do you see me reference can
you send me this and they just oh i got
it i got it i get to it reflects
okay yeah so not following up
and and
yeah okay can you teach us more about
the money side of the film industry and
how that money flows
yes um so
yes make it simple when i did my first
short film girl smith decision be my
boxing film
um
after i did a film i invested five
dollars in the movie and i made all my
money back and more in a weekend
i have a lot of friends i have
associates
i ran out of movie theater before covert
and um everybody came out it's no
different than if you have a baby shower
you have a birthday party or a house
party you charge
and i charge some tickets
i bought some merch because i learned
all this from the business side when
you're doing music you have merch you
have this and that and i made
i made like around 15 000 for my first
show
this was in new york city before coffee
okay so
may i ask how much was the theater
rental the daily rich at the time was
like
nine hours
for like two hour window or the whole
day the whole day wow that's really
great that was a few years ago not now
and how many seats a hundred
okay so what i did was
i took over the whole data for two days
so i did friday saturday
and since it was a whole day it was a
short film
i got other short films
the show before monster get they crowd
to buy tickets and i had merchandise
there i sold food there i had a whole
thing going on and that's how i was able
to make some money so did you make the
food or you got outside vendors and
split family made food oh your family
okay wow
what did you serve chicken wings mac and
cheese
and yeah it was good
okay and you were selling merch for the
short film yeah for the movie yep
okay so i went to like you know you
could go online
and get the print shirts and buy a few
and and sell them yeah sure and so uh
may ask how much were the tickets uh
tween
twenty dollars okay and so that included
how many films uh three films three
films okay so yeah and while i was
showing it so
each day i did like four showings
oh yeah so i had a whole day
yeah so i had the whole day so i did
multiple shows i did i did that with
another my first feature life's too
short i brought the whole theater and i
showed multiple times
and then what i also do to help the film
i cast people that have a fallen
so the film i had
people knew they had a lot of friends
and oh my my daughter's in a movie my
cousin in the movie they all come out so
you guys it's like little recipes you
got to do when you especially when
you're casting
so yeah
sure okay wow yeah and so that was what
2019 2018 i know my first one my
my short film that was like eight nine
years ago
my feature film my life too short that
was me four or five years ago and i did
it again with lola
the last year no last year the year
before covet math at the day new york
shutdown in march the video i seen the
video i sold out ticket sales and
everything and i was selling 30 tickets
for that one an amc movie theater
so you guys screen the day before uh the
day of march
shut it down okay in a while yeah so
wow but yeah so it's like once you do a
project
you know film festivals are great but
film festivals is not really going to
get you a lot of money so do like little
screenings you know now you can do drive
tools do anything that you make money
get your friends to come out make it
it's no different than back in the day i
don't know about y'all guys but i just
do house parties you charge make some
money back
you know you know you you wouldn't know
your choose friends when you put a price
tag on a product who your real
supporters are well i don't have kids
but do people do babies they charge for
baby showers no i'm just saying that to
get your friends and family come out
treat like a baby
cause they're gonna give you gifts for
your babies i was like oh yeah it's
treated like in your film it's your baby
shower did your baby come out about buy
a ticket it was a gift okay right so
instead of a rattler and a pink little
you paid for tickets yeah it's a baby
you just made it
okay
have you ever had it where it hasn't
worked out no it's not and that's never
happened okay only in the music business
i remember i was doing the showcases
with the artists there was fights
shootings
it was
because the the
video the music i was playing working
with was aggressive music it was gang
stuff so it never worked out i thought
i didn't make the money but the film
business i've been good because i
realized that
you got to control your emotions
meaning don't do things on posts
like really
pre-production so if you do predictions
of your film do pre-protection for your
business make sure everything's right
but yeah never
then guard never had a problem